TV road trip who's excited to go to
Bloomington is that where you're gonna
sit
I'm driving where else would I sit trunk
I thought you weren't gonna do
galentine's Day this year because that
she beast moved away I believe her name
was Satan her name is Anne oh the GPS
says we should take 495 to 270 but check
out this cool alternate route oh my God
that is so interesting to me because I
am a map salesman okay well Photoshop
his face can you photoshop your life
with better
of him and his music so this isn't
really about being right it's more about
being supportive
oh wow I didn't realize you were a
marriage counselor Anne
sorry
my instinct is to be mean to you I
understand I want another nurse well
there are none we're stretched pretty
thin right now then I want a janitor
they can do what you do right yep nurses
and janitors are totally interchangeable
except no one dresses up like a janitor
when they want to be
I actually think you look really good
except for the
stick up your butt what do you think
Druid was it Nathaniel Ellis man I feel
like these interns do not respect or
like me at all honestly you could loosen
up a bit on the font stuff
and everything in general
oh wow look at that
did you draw that
uh nope I didn't no no no no it's really
good I mean you're
a you're a great artist I can't do this
look
I don't care who you're related to I'm
your boss and you can't keep
disrespecting me like this man I didn't
draw it
your daughter did it what
her
April's not my daughter she's my friend
does everyone think she's my daughter
whatever point is she would never do
that to me
sorry Dad
I love games that turn people against
each other
you guys will never believe what I just
found on Jerry's Facebook a friend burn
so are you gonna vote for me sister
April it's unethical for me to show you
favoritism you and I are like family
coffee is seven dollars yes right of
course might be able to sneak out early
you get snacks I'll bring music we'll
jam out to some sweet tunics you know
what this is awesome actually no I don't
want to go anymore oh okay just kidding
see you in 10 minutes okay just kidding
we're not going
road trip so we're going yes
where's Jerry by the way why isn't he
back how long does it take to fill bird
feeders maybe you fell into the toilet
remember when he fell into the toilet oh
sorry guys sorry I'm late I got confused
and took a shower after I got dressed
because I'm Jerry
you might like a fresh set of pillows
are you trying to smother me
okay never mind stay back
do you like my nails
April you finalized the rental right
shut up man I told you never to talk to
me
that was Champion oh my God I'm sorry
bad dog yes everything's fine with the
rental Ben you know that I despise you
and that I want you and all people on
Earth to be miserable right sure what
does Leslie always say I don't know
weird stuff about waffles come on April
get in your piece come on do it get some
money I don't care about that prize but
I'm gonna win because I want his
happiness to go away
hey getting ready for your nightly Skype
date with Andy in London you look lovely
I'm going to murder you a thousand times
distance between April
give us a chance to get a little closer
maybe even I don't like Anne
soundtrack to Pulp Fiction soundtrack to
Singles soundtrack to Gross Point Blank
why do you have so many soundtracks oh
well uh I kind of look at it like it's
your favorite directors making a mixtape
just for you oh hey Ann
nurse or do they fire you because you
slept with all the doctors do you want
to try that again
getting a new phone do you guys like
your phones I've never used a phone in
my life
[Music]
dude do you play ultimate yeah I play
intramural a Georgetown dude so did I in
college oh you guys should get married
[Music]
my blankets are on the floor
do you want the door open or shut open
spine okay
I hope you like Tori Amos oh cool
what and I just stole your phone and
texted every guy in it that the baby was
there it's not that big of a deal data
had never felt this way before of course
data had never felt anything before but
Captain Picard couldn't help but note
the smile that crept over his mechanical
but life-like face I'm gonna murder you
I understand just one sec as they walked
down the hall into the bridge we have a
couple house rules though yeah sure of
course you can't use the front door you
have to climb in through the back window
no personal phone conversations if you
ever speak to me in Spanish please use
the formal usted and no electricity
after 6 pm
you can use as much free electricity as
you want it's free a couple more rules
if you ever watch a sad movie you have
to wear mascara so we can
there's no noise a lot on Mondays and no
TV after breakfast hey April I was
looking to get some new music and I was
wondering if you could recommend
anything the internet I really like your
haircut where'd you get it prison how's
your sister doing she has the shingles
who's your favorite character on Sex in
the City
Alf yeah I love cupcakes
Alice hates you Annie has herpes
problem my problem is you smell us Ben
told you to finish the website and if
you don't do it I swear to God I'm gonna
murder you in your sleep I know where
you live 14th Street right I'm gonna get
a melon baller and scoop your eyes out
and
Congressman uncle's gonna have to buy
you a dog to drag your eyeless face
around
do you understand
me do it okay
I wanted to make fun of stupid people
while I get drunk my two true Passions
being nice made me feel terrible I took
Ron's advice I very maturely and
straightforwardly left Anonymous
comments about Donna online
it's kind of weird when she just starts
raining compliments on you huh don't try
to bond with me
can't win is your name Glenn yeah I sat
behind you in middle school band do you
still play the clarinet
yeah
have you been man
so I long for a day when women in
government will simply be seen as people
in government but until then I will work
to make Pawnee my wonderful Hometown as
good as it can be
what do you think I think you should
lose the first line and the last line
and all of the other lines and instead
just walk up to the mic and meow really
loudly for eight minutes okay Anne's
leaving town and saying painful goodbyes
loved ones
greatest day of my life
all right